first of all so much to talk to you
about
let's start with you making history at
the mtv vmas you were the first male
country artist to perform at the award
show what was that moment like
uh it was awesome um
you know we didn't get to perform a
country song but uh i still think people
you know the the intro was saying that i
was a country artist so if anybody has
never heard of me before and they heard
that song they probably went down a
rabbit hole of my other music with this
opening
for more artists which i've been trying
to do this whole time that i've been a
musician so it was really exciting
that's amazing listen you're so used to
performing on stage at this point but
when you have a moment like that does it
feel different when you're on stage at
the mtv vmas
no i didn't feel different um you know
it looked like it was a lot of my fans
out there but i was so excited uh the
energy crazy in the crowd
um that's what i mean any performer
that's all they ask for um so i mean i
had a blast would love to do it again
sometime
met taylor swift uh she was the first
female to do it as a country artist so
it was it was cool
yeah you posted this great photo of you
in taylor swift does she say anything to
you uh she invited me to the after party
but i told her i had two kiddos that i
had with me so i had to
take them back home
look at you making the right choice in
being a good dad
would this have been you like five years
ago no i've been there yeah i'll see you
there
listen you got the invite that's all
that matters right yeah yeah yeah maybe
yeah i love that uh so different man is
the name of the album what did you want
to say with this new music
i mean we've been working on it for
forever i would just say that um
you know i kind of found the sound that
i wanted i got the um
help out in the studio a lot with the uh
with like the halftimes and instruments
that were used and
definitely just changed
the way i perform on stage i feel like i
just really found myself as an artist
and i'm continuing to to grow more and
more but that's just that's basically
what i meant by different man for the
album
i love that when you talk about you know
you're really putting out what you want
to showcase your talents the sound that
you want how do you describe the sound
on this album
um
i mean honestly i definitely feel like
it's a little bit
there's some songs that are like heavy
uh rock country i would say
um and then also
still vulnerable uh michael my wife um
thank god and uh still some love songs
but they're they're different than what
i've released before they're like
they're fun
um
and of course i had to throw like a slow
slow type country song i like whiskey
sour and pop's class name yeah that's a
good
leader
did we know your wife could sing that
well
i did
you who did she's amazing yeah i think
the die hard fans knew
but i don't think anybody else when i
said she could sing really took it
serious
i mean it's such a powerful song i just
i was looking it up and and i was just
like is this is the first time we're
hearing it quite like this what made
this song such a great duet
uh well we've been looking for a duet
for a while and this song um i started
my pub company one of my writers
actually sent this to me for me
and as i kept listening to it kept
listening to it i went and showed it to
kate and she fell in love with it i was
like we could actually probably make
this a do it
um but we had to change some of the
lyrics in the second verse and that's
what she said
oh i love that what was the big thing
that you needed to change
uh it was just
lyrics like towards a girl and so yeah i
got that yeah yeah
okay so who is the bigger perfectionist
when putting this song together you or
your wife
um i think it would have been me on this
one because she would say
she loves like big voices like whitney
houston or
like a carrie underwood or christina
aguilera and uh so she was trying to do
basically she was just trying to
showcase her voice and everything she
could do she can do like crazy runs and
stuff um i just didn't hear it for this
song
i thought it was just a sweet you know
right to the point we're both singing on
it like that's all it should be so uh
whenever she
if we do another one or if she puts one
out or something i'm sure that she'll
showcase her voice a little bit more
oh i love that so overall you enjoyed
collaborating with your your wife
caitlyn on this
it was fun yeah i'm excited to see uh
whenever she gets up on stage with me
it'll be cool chemistry it'll be like
we're in our house just hanging out oh i
love that now does it make you nervous
at all
working with her knowing she'll be on
stage with you or like you said like
it'll just be comfort
no no no i think the only thing is she
she goes uh through bad anxiety so once
we get through that i think it'll be
like a
i'm already very comfortable up there
and once she is i think it'll just be
like you know
a cakewalk
i love that so listen this is so
impressive like i love country music has
spent seven weeks at number one at
country radio did you expect that this
much love for this song
uh no i well i thought that we would get
a good reaction out of it i didn't
expect it to be seven week number one
canada so uh thank you country radio um
but i do love the song
i was really excited to put it out
and now i just can't wait to come to
canada and play
i love that do you celebrate moments
like that
uh
i would say i just hold them in my heart
oh
i love that what do you celebrate these
days i mean obviously you're passionate
about your music but what deserves a
celebration at this point in your life
i don't know you know i'm just if
my my life is good and
i have a i have a beautiful family i
think that's like the celebration
that's a perfect answer well i know
you're going on tour next year and the
title of your tour is fantastic drunk or
dreaming how'd you come up with that
title
oh that's a song on the album
yeah one of my favorite songs that's
very beachy uh just makes me happy when
i listen to it
okay that'll be my next summer single
hopefully you think so hope so
okay so the question is do you find
yourself on an average day
more drunk or dreaming
uh
probably dreaming i try not to drink as
much as possible when i'm off the road
that's good
you know
what does tour life look like for you
these days yeah uh my family's usually
always out with me unless it's uh
like we're about to go to australia uh
they're not going to come with me there
but when i come to canada they'll more
than likely be with me
on stage and everybody considers singing
i love that how much you miss your
family when they're not on tour with you
um well i'm not gonna lie to you uh if
i'm gone for like one day you know it's
kind of like a
you just get to sit there and do your
own thing
a little break yeah but i think i think
day two that's when like you you wake up
and you're like oh like where's kingsley
you know i can't get to play with her or
uh i wake up and have coffee or anything
like that so
day two is where it kind of strikes me
i love that so you have this great
collaboration with your wife any other
artist that you would love to
collaborate with not even artists you
know within the country music genre
yeah i'm gonna keep saying it um
my two right now that i really work with
is uh al dean which i've been wanting to
work with for a while and uh i would
call him a name on here but i can't say
it uh and then
second i would say my boy jack harlow
i'm gonna keep putting it in the
universe until it happens we keep
texting i keep seeing myself in the
media with him
um just gotta make it happen so you are
texting him
yeah he's actually got a show on
nashville today
oh my god what wait how did jack harlow
get into the mix here
uh it all started um celebrity all-star
basketball game
was the first time we met and then it's
just kind of
we keep kind of running into each other
what do you love about his music
uh it's just fun i like his music um
i've seen i've followed him on instagram
i mean sandstone because uh his shows
that he's been doing overseas and things
like that and he kind of reminds me of
myself as a person
um
yeah he's cool
that's cool hey i want to see this
happen now you've put this up in the
universe it has to happen yeah let's see
awesome kane thanks so much for your
time man
yeah thank you
nice seeing you bye
you